je ne les ai pas dit je n'ai pas parlé
avec lui au journaliste eric rochant
téléphone appelle le et demande lui joué
par les tu dis n'importe quoi en les
zones in fine ce qui l'a eu une fuite
comme quoi eric naulleau sera pas dans
l'émission et que jean luc mélenchon
l'avènement du mais évidemment mais ça y
est c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'après je
vous dis je vous affirme tout cas ce que
j'avais dans les yeux que cette fuite
ce que je constate c'est que plaisance
il faudra qu'on ya eu d'autres il faut
inviter retire ce que tu as dit sinon je
me barre voilà je te le dis tout de
suite je me barre de l'émission
je n'ai pas parlé à ce jour de liesse
qui n'a pas parlé mais s'il le sait tout
le monde le sait c'est dedans et garidou
continue dans sont dans sa ligne droite
en 10 ans si tu as parlé c'est de la
déloyauté
je n'ai pas les terres marginales cette
carte lella par les recettes parce
qu'elle est partie au parloir elle
compte les filiales et 4 il ya des
quatre appels demandant vérifie tout de
suite si mais en fait si je lui par les
unes aux autres que franchement
l'émission hier soir était mieux sans
toi si on va parler d'une élection une
fois que tu auras retirer ce que tu as
dit parce que c'est un débat toi qui me
donne la parole ou six naulleau ci ra
c'est moi qui m'intéresse à dire des
mensonges toutes antennes comme c'est un
débat que ta tête pour ils sont que des
gosses des mensonges parce que là tu vas
trop loin et bar sur la véranda parce
que c'est faux ce rythme lorsqu'on a un
été des ministres en marche le parisien
dans son article a dit eric naulleau a
refusé de révéler des spectateurs c'est
les fans matin savoir en demandant
qu'est ce qui se passe dans la vie
d'eric naulleau
je viens de raconter que je voudrais ce
que je voudrais raconter c'est que par
exemple quand on a eu d'autres invités
des ministres en marche par exemple qui
ont effectivement trop préparé
l'émission avec les équipes de
production
par exemple lorsqu'on a invité le porte
parole du gouvernement
gabriella talent et que finalement il
n'y avait aucun chroniqueur parce qu'on
a évité des jeunes pour un dispositif
était du coup ben ça
sa voix parce qu'il voulait faire
vraiment unis où il m'avait demandé de
faire une émission avec les jeunes pour
avoir leur faire ça est donc s'il m'a
pas dit tel ou tel chrono il m'a dit je
voudrais avoir les chaussures genre il
ya eu il ya eu mon lot d'ailleurs et
pendant la ville attire les missions
avec moi donc me voilà car il d'ailleurs
j'ai lu dans le parisien que ya fallu
demander au ministre qui veut bien
vouloir accepter karim parce que le
ministre lui il était plutôt question
sur les jeunes du canton mais prépare
une émission il ya des règles on peut
faire une belle émission une marque pour
la présidentielle il n'y a pas à avoir
un membre de l'équipe qui commença à
péter un câble parce qu'il n'est pas
invitée et à faire des tweets en disant
on veut pas de moi et a inventé la sur
soi disantes a été menacée par un homme
de 69 ans mais tu me fais de la peine
d'inventer sa vie c'est vrai qu'il a dit
merci + prouve le contraire mais roland
melanson on parle aussi des longs
ballons ce ton post t'es pas là et bêtes
en fait des caisses pour qu'on parle de
toi et ben bravo star m6 est un énorme
pas les serbes convient jeunes et les
normales ou qui n'ont pas d'appétit un
cas je n'ai pas pas insurgé analystes je
ne peux pas te dire que ça m'a fait
plaisir j'en ai voulu à cyril pendant un
quart d'heure mais simplement sert il
était dans une position schizophrène
comme animateur il aurait préféré que je
sois là je ne sais oui non c'est vrai
comme producteur voisine se dit il se
dit que la condition pour que mélenchon
viennent il fait des caprices c'est que
je ne sois pas là il a choisi en tant
que producteur je peux le comprendre que
ça m'est fait plaisir ce serait un
mensonge ne m'a pas mais j'en ai pas
fait des cas je suis passé à autre chose
ensuite fois par dessus ça tu rajoutes
des mensonges mais tu es le mensonge
maintenant mais ça c'est dit
alors méfiance